Vô quen khách khiến nhồng người vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa
Vừa người đẹn ông gặp sang đường chờ phía sau là bỏ
thì bánh ở phát hiện một tờ tiền rồi dưới rồi rồi
không có mạnh giá bao nhiêu như phản giá quen là nhân hơn cả xuy nghĩ
bánh bỏ luôn vừa là chia sè lâu thằng ra lòng đường đến nha tờ tiền
bất chấp xe cầu đăng qua lại
Cánh tờ dễ ra chỉ trong vai dây như đủ kến rồi chúng kến dẫn mình vì quán quý hợp
chỉ cần một chia sè phóng nhành
một của phán khu kìp là họ quả khó lợp
nhưng người xè xong chỉ biết là đâu
vì một tất hiện mà đến cộng cả con của bản thân
giúp chỉ còn là vừa mình bảo tình vũi nhập
tiền có thể nhật lại như thế nào thì không có có có có có sợ giải